energy level is high played a couple of
years of San Diego State and finished up
elsewhere and there is hot jhamora
inside of them jump book club that bust
up that's on the announcement of Zion
Williamson being the number one pick
they signed some 10,000 new season
tickets he turned to play in
availability he and his staff have sort
of redefined the way the game is played
baseball as opposed to basketball and
his name actually translates as he
knocks down the jump shot the number one
pick and played one game last night will
play again for the summer league assange
immoral it's time to get to work
tomorrow with a fully baseline move
underneath state that same school as
Kawhi Leonard hot Chamorro when the nice
finish with the off panicking inside a
reason why if he's inside put us into
penalties it put your the penalty also
it gets yourself as a wing guy a better
love his guys he comes to games to see
them play he even comes to see these
cups to see me play yep and he didn't
post me he was cool out of the guys on
the Carolina staff here you know and I
see I see a lot of coaches here do it
it's really cool to see even throughout
the regular season
see the drug to go out of their way to
be at some of their old former players
games like Tommy so what I'm saying in
Vince's speaking and that because he's
Atari oh I could a man added and watch
Android now comfortable you're you're a
veteran of the of Summer League so now
communicate to your young guys and that
kind of helps them and it gets them
engaged it's cleared by Matthews who
gives it up for Hachi Mora who he loves
the mid-range market against Nick steps
through 4:15 found Ben we're telling him
and of course that's grown watch this
move right here watch the shot fake
little step through but you know again I
don't want to be compared Robinson the
good eye Hachi Murrah gets it into 14
feet and connects pretty good good shot
fake by the way I think they ought to
move the NBA line back to 25 feet it's a
23 nine right now why do you think that
would be better
he's gonna make pretty good money with
that first NBA contract but he's gonna
wait make way more money and all those
endorsements back home in Japan where
although baseball is a national sport
the bat we talked about how good he is
in the mid-range and how he reminds me a
little bit of Kawhi Leonard on to the
Green Bay in Luxemburg next thing you
know he's in the NBA Finals and it goes
back to what I said run your own race
look at this now what he adds that watch
out an NBA athlete right now but they're
trying to show his wares do you think
with another eye what a block by Hachi
Murrah a is right now if you think about
it as teams
the future is now right for the Lakers
the Clippers
the Nets then the future is the future
for teams like Memphis and Washington
Atlanta good a little pick-and-roll
action right here by copain and you know
listen this is summer league this is
like double-a it's like the double-a
baseball all-star game okay
my cousins Fran Fraschilla with me her
the Thomas & Mack Center Atlanta up by
two and Hachi Morra evens the school
George wanted al if you wanted to go to
the Lakers with with Kawhi Leonard and
they Sam Presti had to trade it what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content